hello everyone this game was suggested
to me by a subscriber and well it's a
blitz game played between Nicolas Luba
and Melanie oh man
Nicolas is an international master and
Melanie is a woman grandmaster and well
the game is interesting because the
stakes to this game are really high as
well the two of them were planning on
getting married this game was played
sometime in November in 2015 and well
the the story goes that they couldn't
decide which family name to use they
didn't want to use like a mixture of
their names for for it to be like Oh me
Luba so they decided to play a blitz
game and the whoever wins decides the
family name so pretty high stakes for a
blades game and I will also put in the
description below
they both recorded their game they
streamed at the game so I will put two
both with a video so you can check out
their own commentary if you if you
understand German that is so let's see
this game and Nicolas is white and
Melanie is a black here we have Knight
to f3 Knight to f6 g3 g6 so the rating
opening Bishop to G to Bishop to g7
castles castles so symmetrical variation
I will have B 3 D 6 e for C 6 rook to e1
Queen to C 7 C 3 we have B 5 Melanie's
expanding on the Queen side I would have
Knight B to d2 Knight B to d7 d 4 D 5
now Queen to c2 rook to e8 and now a 4
and okay Melanie here develops the
Bishop Bishop to b7 and we have a
capture some b5 we have seek after some
b5 + b5 this grabbing some more space
here in the center now controlling this
c6 and e6 squares and this well this
limits the the influence of this light
square Bishop on b7 and we have a 5 here
by Melanie Bishop to f1 now adding
pressure to this b5 porn queen to b6
defending the pawn and our
three I will have Bishop to e6 King to
g2 rocky to c8 Queen to b3 and well this
Queen to b3 wasn't really such a such a
great plan as Melanie's that they'll
instantly place a knight to c5 attacking
this Queen and b3 and the pin has to go
back so Queen 31 and what black is much
better in this position well not much
better but better we have B for Bishop
captures on a6 rook captures an a6 and
now C for not allowing the position to
open up and we have b3 and this is a
very good position for black but Nikolas
doesn't really mind the threats on the
Queen side he decides to open up the
Kings side he plays g4 we have a for
continuing on the Queen side and we have
worked to be one if a threes ever played
and the B captures and a3 said this rook
will be adding pressure to this b3 pawn
as the 19th Queen are already attacking
it
we have h6 and rook to e3 now adding
even more pressure to the b3 pawn and
well not allowing ideas like Knights to
d3 we have King to h7 and now Knight the
e one night after d7 Queen to f3 and in
this position well this Queen to f3 is
attacking this f7 pawn but a best
resource for black here would actually
be to play Bishop to f6 and this would
completely stop any idea Whitehead on
attacking on the Queen on the King side
but we have kinked the g8 and now Rock
the c3 we have nice the b8 night to f1
rook to a7 adding protection to the f7
square we have Bishop to e3 now painting
this night a night beat a six defending
this night and also preparing to go to
before we have night to d2 night the be
for now and now Knight to d3 now
attacking this c5 Knight one more time
we have night beat after Sun d3 rook
captures some beat on d3 and of course
rook cannot be captured as the knight is
pinned so Queen to be
or unpinning and we have Bishop captures
on c5 wrote captures on c5 and rook to
a-1 not allowing any a3 ideas we have
rocked the b7 Nichols goes quinta III he
is preparing to push f4 to break open
the Kings side and here Melanie plays it
bishop to f8 and well a much better idea
would a much better idea here would be
something like King to h7 so the rook
can so drew can go behind this point
this F pawn to add protection to it but
you play the bishop to f8 and this will
be well this would be this will be a
valuable tempo that was lost
we have h4 here King the g7 and now g5
we have h5 not allow me to open up and
f4 we have he captures an f4 Queen
captures on f4 and our Bishop to e7 and
already in the cost was robbed de f1 is
attacking this f7 square and well we
have Bishop the e8 a Bishop to d8 and
now the rook is defending f7
but here comes rogue D to F 3 adding
even more pressure here and well the
threat is pretty strong threat is the
threat is capturing here on f7 if if if
it becomes possible so let's see if
maybe the Queen can capture it
immediately
for example if if black tried something
like let's say what's the a3 if this was
played this would be instant checkmate
for example Queen captures on f7 check
and after this rook captures the Queen
rook captures King that King goes to g8
rope to f8 checking back to g7 and group
to f7 checkmate so after this Bishop to
d8 we had a rogue d2 F 3 and now Bishop
to b6 and Nikolas here didn't find Queen
captures on f7 as he could have played
the checkmate in four moves he played a
5 but it didn't really matter in this
position male and it was already down to
one sec
and so after e5 he/she captured he
captures on e5 and here we had Queen
captures on e5 with check and Melanie
lost some time in this position but even
if she didn't with the best defense here
it still made him five with the same
idea
for example f6 Queen captures on f6 with
check King to h7 Queen to f7 now
sacrificing the Queen for checkmate rook
captures rook captures and after two
forced moves by the King it's a double
rook checkmate
so yeah a very nice game and like I said
very very high stakes for a glitz game
so as as I try to watch the video but my
German isn't really that great so I
didn't really understand much and I I
didn't I didn't really check which name
they used after they got married so
maybe some of you know which name they
used so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and you know if you're
ever in a dilemma which family name to
use and you can't come to an agreement
with your with your fiance you know you
can always play a chess game to the side
so yeah that's it I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon